Baba Booey
come on John
how you doing everybody all right my
name is Melissa this is my mom Joan
don't look at me I'm still in shock over
[ __ ] tan mom
good for you what a show I was the only
kid that wishes her mother was Casey
Anthony when I think of this crowd John
what is look at this crowd how to tan
mom get in here where'd she get Lou
Reed's tickets Wow junko this is Lindsay
Lohan's other half of the coke
I stole it from her TIPA TIPA tan any
you wanted Howard Stern has been in
radio so long he bought Robin and an
auction
suppose
where's my private parts and where's my
private parts fans
yes our Oh
they're doing a sequel to private parts
only this time it's about Robyn's career
it's called 32 years of slave now you're
judging we left it every other [ __ ]
joke
now you're judging how would you do so
much for animals yet you keep robbing in
a glass cage enough about robbing I
first of all I'm thrilled you're back
thank you I am thrilled and you know I
love you because you're the only black
woman in America who is not [ __ ] Wilmore
ah
except for Al Roker Pitt otherwise you
uh you are a bride if I might say to
your race I just want to say this yes to
your people your people cost you your
doorman your elevator man your horse
trainer your limo driver because you
always talk about your love black people
when was the last time seriously you
talk to a black person except to say the
vacuum cleaner is in the closet you let
me think I love you Howard Howard I love
you you're like a Jewish rock star the
guns and noses what man you win I want
my nickel back send them home never no
jokes about you because I think you look
very handsome now and I want to know the
60 people that we touch the invitation
you look so good and they said do jokes
about his face they told me this do
jokes about his face and I can't because
it's not that you're not attractive give
your face for a car it would be Paul
Walker's Porsche you know
how is the river partum 18 years old
what that's right oh hey no I think he's
Joey's here just Rosie where's the
beautiful Beth stern tonight right Beth
you look so beautiful no sage I'm gonna
send them in your wedding gift cuz it's
working go ahead everywhere Howard goes
you know he keeps a picture of Beth in
his wallet
and everywhere Beth goes she keeps a
picture of Howard's wallet oh come on
geez that's so terrible the two of you
are terrific together don't you ever let
anybody say that but I only hear about
the age different too [ __ ] bad right
either she knows no matter how old you
lift you before you die she'll still
have 30 more years to enjoy the money so
it's all right right it's all right
Harry hey Harry let me just say
everybody's talking about how many
people know that I'm not making a joke
Howard Stewie and I knew you a little
stupid room and NBC yeah you knew me way
back remember that yes ru but then he
went over to E and that was when the
career started change and he was the
biggest hit show for 11 years on E which
is an amazing accomplishment Oh having
the biggest show on ease and way like
having the best sex of your life with a
[ __ ] man and it's like and I should
know because I slept with Dane Cook but
that's just
Howard we just want to say yeah you're
our comedy hero you're all our comedy
hero I learned so much about life
listening to your show you are the
Johnny Carson of my generation and the
Mark Twain of Jones generation we love
you so much thank you thank you thank
you for being here good boy
Joan Rivers and Jeffrey Ross everybody
she'd have a seat right there yes yes
have a seat you guys made it to the
couch it sit down
you know what you two did so well that
I'm gonna let you like Johnny Carson
let's just sit on the couch you know
what I mean you've been pulled over by
the King to be called over that was the
worst part in China Carson I don't get
that if you only did good you got to sit
on the couch yes right that's right
that's right it's obnoxious
yeah by the way your biggest competition
on JDate is here Barbara Walters who's a
very good friend yes you two hang out
you had those my god and when we get
really old yeah we're gonna get an
apartment together and share a nurse we
talked about this do you invite Barbara
to your parties the ones where she won't
go naked she won't but you have parties
I've been to one of them who's the last
one I ever went to because Joan will cut
crusts of bread yeah and will actually
make cress sandwiches like what is this
she that's when she stopped being Jewish
she became a Protestant it's
unbelievable Jeffrey Ross look at you
thank you it's unbelievable how your
career is going thank you our thanks for
making me going it's going fantastic
Howard mentioned me every day on the on
the air this week and I really
appreciate that I did my show sellout
every time you mention my name daddy
right are you serious yeah because when
I mentioned Joan say nothing happened
really weird I don't understand it by
the way I want to do I did this for Joan
and a lot of people don't know this this
couch tonight is actually made from
Johnny Carson's bones it's his actual
skin that you're sitting on so whatever
happens happens I believe it is you're
waiting for a joke there's no joke does
that me see it's so weird to be doing a
show in front of an audience
honestly I like it better in the studio
where no one sees my face
Joan introduced us to the animal you're
wearing around your neck go with that
this is the other half of Lindsey
Lohan's coat
I got we said last night my wife I what
my wife wants to adopt that animal
around your neck and I gonna how would I
know it our own I would note for I have
four dogs all rescues this if you eat
meat and your wish you were 11 don't be
a goddamn hypocrite this has gone places
it wouldn't have gone when it was alive
hi honey throw the red paint on drones
out the clue how you know Joan you know
where she shops right forever 71 it's
all right Jeff where do you shop I got
this out of your closet Jimmy Jimmy the
birthday show is going very very well is
it going well yes I've been roasted I've
met the black bees we had Rob Zombie out
here we've had a lot of fun so far we
have a lot more fun coming up in fact go
it's time for some music would you guys
like out Oh Joan are you gonna dance
with me here Joan and Jeff with us at
the back let's use my phone
Jeff Rossen Joan Rivers everybody our
next performer was gracious enough